j'ai une petite sœur qui est en
situation de de handicap donc c'est un
lourd handicap sur lequel on n pas de de
nom encore mal généti il y en a plus de
7000 et on les connaît pas toutes je me
suis rendu compte que la solidarité
c'était pas que sur le terrain
finalement ça pit être aussi dans la vie
de tous les
jours chacun peut être acteur à son
échelle on a besoin du Team EDF pour
relayer ce
message être associé à un team qui
soutient des valeurs qui sont les
miennes ça reste une grande fierté c'est
beau de se rendre compte que tu es pas
toute
[Musique]
seule je m'appelle Anne cécileopanie
j'ai 29 ans je suis joueuse
professionnelle de rugby à 7 et je
prépare Paris 2024 au sein du team EDF
le 7 en étant beaucoup moins nombreux
sur le terrain finalement tu as moins
cet aspect frontal c'est beaucoup plus
aéré je trouve il y a des essais tout le
temps tu vois à 15 l'essai tu l'attends
c'est comme un peu au foot le but tu
l'attends et quand il viens
effectivement c'est une explosion de
joie mais à 7 c'est du spectacle presque
ça fait
longtemps même si c'est dur je me suis
dit mais non c'est là que je veux être
le fait d'avoir trouvé un sport dans
lequel je pouvais exploiter complètement
mes mes qualité dépasser quotidiennement
mes capacités vraiment c'était quelque
chose que je je me pensais pas capable
et je me suis vraiment redécouverte et
c'est un monde dans lequel je suis bien
je suis très très
bien en 2021 donc ça a été j'avoue une
très belle année côté perso donc avec la
médaille olympique qui a également eu un
un titre de meilleure joueuse du monde 6
mois après les jeux mais je peux pas
oublier les copines qui étaient là et
qui ont énormément contribué à ce titre
là la solidarité dans dans une équipe
comme celle-ci c'est c'est primordial et
c'est beau de se rendre compte que tu es
pas pas toute
[Musique]
seule image positive de
moi-même scénario positif dans ma
pratique sportive
ok c'était trop dur je crois que j'ai
vraiment plus rien plus rien plus rien
plus rien avec cette sensation c'est
qu'on a bien travaillé Team EDF le team
dans lequel je suis c'est une autre
équipe c'est un autre notre collectif
qui me soutient aussi et et que j'ai
envie de rendre fier du coup c'est c'est
toute une équipe qui est qui est
derrière moi aussi et et je suis
derrière tous ces athlètes également le
Team EDF c'est autant d'hommes que de
femmes il y a également donc des paras
et des Olid on est tous ensemble dans un
seul et même team la solidarité dont
dont peut faire preuve également EDF
c'est le le soutien à différentes causes
à différentes associations et notamment
le le Téléton moi me semble hyper
important donc à titre personnel aussi
je je suis assez sensible à cette cause
contente que vous puissiez me être mon
guide bah je vais essayer voilà on est
un peu dans le cœur de du Téléton
ou celui qui a apporté le Téléton qui a
eu l'idée de de créer Téléton en France
Bernard barato il travaillait chez EDF
EDF lui a permis quand il a appris la
maladie de son fils son fils était
atteint de myopati du chne il a perdu
son fils à l'âge de 17 ans il a pu être
mis à disposition pour pouvoir se
consacrer pleinement à l'association à
la FM et puis c'est devenu ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui à l'époque on ne connaissait
pratiquement rien de ces maladies on
connaissait rien des maladies qu'on
appelle les maladies rares et c'est des
maladies qui touchent pour la plupart
des enfants la moitié de ces maladies
sont mortelles et souvent avant l'âge de
ans bonjour j'ai ma petite sœur qui est
lourdement handicapé et on n pas de nom
justement sur sa maladie il y a pas de
réel traitement elle a 13 ans
aujourd'hui et c'est 13 ans de
d'incompréhension en fait effectivement
il faut mettre un nom exactement sur le
sur la maladie un nom sur le coupable et
c'est qui a été le déclencheur de la
création de ce laboratoire au départ il
y a des différences qui sont
pathologiques qui provoquent une maladie
notre ADN c'est un filament qui fait 2 m
de long et pourtant ça tient dans
quelque chose qu'on voit pas à l'œil nu
et ça ça s'appelle une méduse et c'est
de l'ADN de l'équivalent de 500 millions
de cellules si je le déroule ce fil là
je fais trois fois la distance terre
lune
ça fait un million de kilomètr c'est pas
possible si si donc on va voir ce que
c'est que une banque d'ADM ça c'est les
coffres
fort c'est les coffres forts de la
banque il y a plus de 400000
échantillons là ça correspond à pas loin
de 500 maladies différentes et plus de
90000 personnes et et c'est congelé on
peut le congeler pour l'éternité comme
ça ça a permis à des chercheurs dans
dans le monde entier de travailler sur
ces maladies et on continue d'en stocker
d'en récupérer opér dans stocker maladie
c'est rien c'est juste de l'azote qui
est en train de rentrer dans
leession d'être dans un labo un peu de
c'est automatique dans les dessins
animés je trouve ça vraiment
impressionnant en fait dans ce labo a
été mis au point une thérapie génique la
thérapie génique c'est prendre un petit
morceau d'ADN ah et et l'injecter dans
l'organisme en espérant qu'il aille au
bon endroit et qu'il fasse son travail
c'est un traitement unique c'est-à-dire
que c'est une perfusion et c'est fini
ces produits là on les fabrique dans des
laboratoires très spécialisés on va
pouvoir visiter maintenant moi j'ai
l'impression de vraiment prendre part à
la recherche le temps le temps d'un
après-midi d'avoir une sœur qui
justement est en situation de handicap
forcément ça me rend beaucoup plus
sensible à tout ça j'ai envie d'être
actrice je me suis surprise le temps
d'enfiler la blouse à être un peu comme
ces
[Musique]
chercheurs est-ce que il y a des
histoires entre guillemets concrète
auquel tu as pu assister on voit des des
enfants qui s'il n'avait pas eu le
traitement n'aurait pas eu le
développement qu'ils ont aujourd'hui la
petite elle s'appelle Lucy Luce elle a
l'amotrophie spinale infantile elle fait
partie des 3000 enfants dans le monde
qui ont été traité par thérapie génique
et un un un médicament dont la
conception a été initiée ici dans ce
laboratoire elle peut sourire tu vois
elle a pas de machine pour l'aider à
respirer c'est tu la distingues pas d'un
autre enfant ouis chaud au cœur aussi de
de se rendre compte qu'il y a des gens
qui se battent pour comprendre et pour
faire avancer les choses et je suis très
très heureuse et très honorée d'avoir pu
fouler les les coulours du Téléton en
compagnie de
ser on peut tous contribuer à ça
l'application EDF sport énergie il
contribue parce que en réalisant une
activité un challenge qu'on transforme
en don qui va à la recherche finalement
on le transforme en médicament donc on
devient acteur de ça passe la balle
enfin il a il a tout
[Musique]
dit c'était mon rêve quand j'étais plus
jeune je je voulais je voulais faire les
jeux dans mon entourage ouais ça a été
un peu
mais l'incompréhension c'est pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé mais le rugby
mais tu es sûr mais tu vas te faire mal
et puis en fait moi j'étais là non non
non moi je veux faire les jeux si c'est
au rugby que je dois faire les jeux et
ben je je je je vais m'y mettre à fond
et en fait ça a été un énorme coup de
cœur j'ai la chance d'avoir déjà fait
une olympiade j'espère en tout cas je
travaille dur pour pouvoir faire la
deuxième qui sera à Paris devant la
famille devant les proches au Stade de
France c'est énorme c'est un rêve
vraiment pour le coup qui va se
réaliser